>> Laura: A NEW INSTALLMENT IN
OUR RAYMOND ON THE ROAD SERIES
TONIGHT.
RAYMOND ARROYO IN SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA, NOW THE HOME OF
PETE BUTTIGIEG.
BUT WHAT DOES THE MAYOR'S REAL
RECORD LOOK LIKE FROM THE
GROUND?
>> FROM THE LOOKS OF THINGS YOU
MIGHT LOOK LIKE I'M IN ST. LOUIS
OR DETROIT BUT ACTUALLY I'M ONLY
A FEW MILES FROM THE GOLDEN DOME
OF NOTRE DAME.
WELCOME TO MAYOR PETE'S,
SOUTH BEND, INDIANA.
A PLACE WHERE THE LOCAL
POPULATION HERE, 25% OF THEM
LIVE BENEATH THE POVERTY LINE
AND CRIME HAS RISEN TO THE 20
YEAR HIGHS WITH VIOLENT ASSAULTS
EXCEEDING BY 173% THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE.
AND IF THERE ARE LOTS OF
ABANDONED HOMES HERE.
"USA TODAY" RECENTLY DESCRIBED
SOUTH BEND AS ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS CITIES IN AMERICA.
THEY SAY IT'S DOUBLED THE AND
STATE AVERAGE FOR ASSAULTS.
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE?
>> WE HAVE A MIRROR THAT IS MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT POLITICS RIGHT
NOW THAN HE IS ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY IN OUR OWN CITY.
IT'S INFURIATING.
>> BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
RHETORIC HERE AT HOME AND
NATIONALLY, AS IT MADE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR YOU TO DO YOUR
JOB?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
NOW THE PUBLIC SEES US AS
VILLAINS.
AND MORALE IS AT AN ALL-TIME LOW
AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
I'VE BEEN A POLICE OFFICER HERE
FOR 27 YEARS AND THIS IS THE
LOWEST I'VE EVER SEEN IT.
IT'S MAINLY DUE TO THE MAYOR'S
LACK OF PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR OUR
OFFICERS.
>> TELL US ABOUT THE ERIC LOGAN
CASE.
>> MORE THAN TEN OFFICERS HAVE
BEEN SHOT AT SINCE THAT SHOOTIN
SHOOTING.
>> TO WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE
THAT?
>> THE PUBLIC IS NOW AFRAID TO
APPROACH US.
>> DO YOU FEEL SAFE IN
SOUTH BEND?
>> NOT AT ALL.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO GET OUT.
>> I FEEL LIKE I'M ON
GAILLARDIA.
>> I'M OKAY WITH WHERE I'M NOT
BUT THERE'S STUFF THAT GOES ON
DOWNTOWN AND OTHER AREAS THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
>> DO YOU GO DOWNTOWN IN
SOUTH BEND?
>> SOMETIMES I DO, IT'S A LOT OF
FIGHTING.
>> I DON'T GO DOWNTOWN.
MY 15-YEAR-OLD DOESN'T LIKE TO
BE OUT ALONE AT NIGHT.
>> IS THERE HOMELESS?
>> THEY ARE ALL OVER THE CITY.
>> 25% LIVE BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVEL.
>> GIVEN WHAT YOU WITNESSED AND
LIVED UNDER, IS HE READY TO
ASSUME NATIONAL OFFICE?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
MY MESSAGE TO THE MAYOR IS TO
DROP THE POLITICS AND BE A
LEADER FOR THE CITY THAT HE
SWORE TO BE A LEADER FOR.
>> AND THEN THERE IS MAYOR PETE
MAYOR PETE'S RECORD ON ABORTION.
IN 2008, THE WOMEN'S CARE
CENTER, A PRO-LIFE CRISIS CENTER
WANTED TO OPEN UP A FACILITY
NEXT TO THAT BUILDING.
THE CITY COUNCIL APPROVED THEIR
PERMIT BUT MAYOR PETE VETOED IT.
>> WE PURCHASED A BUILDING THAT
NEEDED TO BE REZONED AND WHEN WE
BROUGHT IT TO THE CITY COUNCIL
THAT APPROVED THE ZONING, IT WAS
VETOED.
THE OWNER OF THE PROPERTY HERE
WHERE WE STAND ACROSS THE STREET
CONTACTED US AND OFFERED US HIS
PROPERTY.
SO WE BUILT HERE AND HERE WE ARE
SERVING WOMEN ON THE WEST SIDE
OF SOUTH BEND.
JUSTICE DEMANDS THAT EVERY WOMAN
IN THIS COMMUNITY, HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE LIFE.
>> YOU CAN SEE IT'S NOT EXACTLY
POPULATED IN THE AFTERNOON BUT
MAYOR PETE HAS INSTIGATED
INVESTMENTS DOWNTOWN.
THERE IS SOME NEW CONSTRUCTION.
THE STUDEBAKER FACTORY HERE WAS
A RECENTLY TURNED INTO A TECH
HUB.
BUT THE QUESTION IS CAN THE
RESIDENCE AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THESE NEW HIGH-RISES?
>> I HAVE TWO CHILDREN, 24 AND
25, I DON'T THINK THEY COULD
AFFORD TO LIVE IN THOSE SPACES.
>> I DON'T SEE A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITY IN THE CITY.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK IT'S FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE MONEY RATHER THAN
THE RESIDENCE.
>> IS MAYOR PETE READY?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
I DON'T AGREE WITH ANYTHING ON
THIS PLATFORM.
>> I LIKE MAYOR PETE.
>> I CAN'T SEE HIM STANDING
TOE-TO-TOE WITH FOOD AND OR
OTHER LEADERS.
WHAT HE'S DONE WITH THE CITY, HE
HASN'T REALLY CHANGED TOO MUCH.
>> Laura: IT RAYMOND ARROYO
JOINS ME NOW.
TERRIFIC REPORTING THERE.
WHAT'S YOUR IMPRESSION OF
SOUTH BEND?
I'VE ONLY BEEN THERE A COUPLE
TIMES BECAUSE OF FOOTBALL GAMES
OR WHATEVER AND NOTRE DAME.
BUT AT LEAST THE PEOPLE YOU
INTERVIEWED, THEY SAID IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE HE'S DOING HIS
JOB AT HOME LET ALONE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE REALLY
LIKE MAYOR PETE.
THEY GIVE HIM CREDIT.
THIS NEW ART CENTER HAS BEEN
REFURBISHED BUT THE STREETS ARE
EMPTY.
THIS IS A DAYLONG APPROACH TO
THE AREA, IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
ABANDONED OR A GHOST TOWN.
ON THE OTHER SIDE THEY SAY THEY
FEEL UNSAFE.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT AND
VIOLENT ASSAULTS.
NOT ONLY HEAR ABOUT IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD.
HE SAW THE HOMELESS PROBLEM WE
UNCOVERED, AND THE HEAD OF THE
POLICE UNION THERE, HARVEY
MILLS, SHARED MORE INFORMATION
WITH US ABOUT THE DRUG UNIT
BEING SHRUNKEN BY MAYOR PETE AS
WELL AS TRAFFIC ENFORCEMENT.
WE HAVE MORE TO SHARE WITH YOU
LATER IN THE SHOW.